[Music]
what's left of the champlain towers in
surfside
now lays in yet another devastating pile
of rubble
the decision to demolish the remaining
portion of the building came over fears
the structure was unstable
potentially putting rescuers lives in
danger officials say it was a
heartbreaking compromise
but they had little choice to collapse
an entire
apartment building is a devastating
decision and the demolition
was in no way a decision that i made
lightly
bringing the building down in a
controlled manner was critical
to expanding our scope of search truly
we could not
continue without bringing this building
down
within hours of the demolition crews
were back on site continuing their
painstaking search for survivors
the priority now is digging a path
through the fresh rubble to reach areas
that have until now
not been searched the approach of
tropical storm elsa is now complicating
rescue efforts
the weather system is likely to bring
heavy winds and rain in the coming hours
and days
another potential hazard in an already
difficult situation
residents should avoid any unnecessary
travel
as strong winds and heavy rains may make
driving hazardous
on monday more victims of the collapse
were pulled from the rubble
but over a hundred people remain
unaccounted for
this is something that's very traumatic
so the mental health aspects are going
to be very very
important and this is something that is
going to be require long-term support
but i can tell you
the support is there access to new parts
of the building
may bring renewed hope for those waiting
for news of their loved ones but it's
been almost two weeks since the collapse
officials say the oncoming storm may now
skirt this area
meaning rescue efforts can continue
undisturbed
the investigation into how this tragedy
happened is still underway
andy gallacher al jazeera surfside
florida